deux boutiques chinoises toute façon
uniquement et rue revient donc à un peu
comme dans tant de temps maintenant les
grandes surfaces et qu'une nouvelle est
plus pareil
ben sékou sylla visionner des boutiques
chinoises
un petit coup détruites et apparemment
aussi d'art boutiques ne trouve de tout
oui oui me trouve de tout 1 à leurs
hommes
na na tout tout tout tout voilà je me
sauvais départ avec de bien tout ça il
fait tout autant
[Musique]
comme si tu ne me connais pas mon papa
mon papa et ma maman optique sinon j'ai
nommé socialiste dans la boutique son
rôle moteur voyages à l'étra politique
voilà comme ont été faits dans catia
soldats pour manger un petit voile un
peu à faire parce qu'elles avaient moins
pas encore
oui votre motif était passé à 2
eni south stream s'il a fait le boulot
c'est un petit gâteau paris france a
demandé non quand ses seuls souvenirs
derrière mais c'est comme ça à l'école
des comme ça balance à l'école ou leurs
grandes villes
voilà bien que manger alors quoi çà et
là
[Musique]
quand même qu'on a besoin de beaucoup
mais ça va aller voir ne gagnent pas de
tir où la tranquille
[Musique]